[Music]
in fire station porn news submitted by
Lewis T Joe malian from the Philippines
oh the least Lewis Lewis that night I
didn't it's very far
a pair of firefighters have been
suspended for making porn inside of
their fire station gay porn well I
wasn't there fire station via a also
they made fireman porn I mean if there's
no fires they've got a lot of time maybe
it was a fire cross you don't know boom
yeah what is that mean
like ginger looking disgusting a
knowledge that deviant crotch deviant
yeah I picture does a girl at the end of
the you know that [ __ ] fire holster
like your party you know that [ __ ]
you know that you know that fire the
stripper pole that fire stripper pole
yeah there's a girl with her leg spray
like that and then the fireman goes down
headfirst and then he lands on her [ __ ]
and eats it Wow have you seen you should
be a director didn't sound like a
twelve-year-old
[Laughter]
twelve-year-old porn I thought it was
pretty hot yeah so these two
firefighters that have been in a
long-term relationship from Ohio two
dudes no man why do you guys keep you
women
[ __ ] firefight yeah but they're
useless alright for all my female
firefighters out there if you're ever
putting us a tracer I have to save Joe
just be like oh yeah we're usually
useless yeah let them burn
all hired that is two guys versus a guy
who is that like a guy and a girl or two
girls or two guys I didn't know or it
could be two gay oh the only reason why
I was asking if it was two dudes it's
because I was thinking of I do with
chuck and Larry murder that film yeah
and I said with a funny ass [ __ ] [ __ ]
we had a fire and in a lady a lady came
with like with a group and I was like
she's buff she could carry me out
Jessica McBeal why the [ __ ] is you
McDonald's menu item Jessica Biel
Jessica Big B she had the nicest [ __ ]
ass in that film wild man like it was
yeah she had a really nice ass that
shit's like a +10 year like spank bank
memory dude that [ __ ] was so good killed
it I like ass too so this story involves
Arthur who's 49 and Deanne who is 42 and
they each work is separate in your head
they were in their 20s and [ __ ] hi
there veteran firefighters oh cool
and so um why is why does he already
look like a dick long [ __ ] dick and
his neck because there's no job yeah
there's a head they look like two naked
and afraid' contestants I bet you
they're strong yes we're cuts making a
porn in a different firehouse not even
how do they even get access to her blood
I don't know you don't [ __ ] where you
sleep man come on now I guess so dude I
can't even believe it's the [ __ ] same
shot like she didn't even do herself up
I know
[Laughter]
shoulders and biceps she's got time to
do makeup she's in burning flames oh I
told you they're strong I told you look
at her face there's another one wait
that she's there doing porn with her
with her bikini is really good yeah so
it was like wait what
oh you're like really love it I mean see
right okay I can't see okay that's the
dude yeah my bad couldn't see this part
that though look what kind of porn are
they she's so [ __ ] already
they look like they're watching TV yeah
yeah I mean I don't know she looks like
she turns her own butter that's what it
looks like like she just lives in one of
those like old societies with them yes
she does yeah she looks like she'd make
a really good farm wife yeah cuz she
would for him and like take care of the
kid you know and that's what you want in
a woman like you want a strong girl that
could rally up all the Bulls together or
the cows someone who could help carry
what are you off all the cows and little
Toki all right huh know someone who
carries the bale of hay no I'm saying
like back in the farm days you know like
you want someone strong that's got some
childbearing hips then [ __ ] that can
help you carry some do you even know
what that means
childbearing hips you know what that
means yeah poison me so you could pop a
lot of babies what does it look like yes
it's big childbearing hips is wide she
has all she has she she's a rectangle
with limbs wait what does that look like
her do I look like no that's back in the
day you talked about that sweet topi
gets the right okay that is a rectangle
final triangle or a square triangle can
you hold this while her arm this is the
ugly ass woman
that's rough
this is her yes ticket leg yeah [ __ ]
legs are hella long this is her where's
your head so you want big bird I'm not
saying that that's I'm just saying that
hey I'm ashamed because I mean I'm
disappointed because women should
support each other but what you're doing
right now is women shaming because you
think beauty only comes in one way and
I'm trying to support I need you to I
need you to listen to this you are
disrespecting this strong farmhand how
exactly how by saying that that's not
beautiful no one said that we said she's
BA yeah who says she's not beautiful
then don't argue with me because she is
Bob don't argue with him okay yeah so
anyway they were both hired in September
of 2000 on the exact same day mmm the
romantic be there has been a wife were
fuck-buddies just in a long-term
relationship oh you can fight fires and
[ __ ] each other and make porn yep are
they getting fired I hope they don't
know they were gross they were placed on
administrative leave I'm two years away
from getting uh the pension - they've
been on since 2000 that's 18 years cuz
after 20 years you get your pension it's
really good what is a pension so like uh
for cops I think if you in California if
you work 20 years you get maybe like I
think like between 60 to 70% of whatever
you make for the rest of your life it's
really good if you're a police officer
so let's say you make a 150 which a lot
of people make over 100 by the time
they're in for 20 years you'll make 60
G's - like 80 GS for like the rest of
your life and if you did really good it
can be 200 or
jeez and then you're getting paid like
200 grand for the rest of your life and
if you die your wife gets that oh you're
a husband but that's also my
California's out of money
that makes sense too hmm yeah so
firefighters get some kissing line oh
well I guess we got to protect our
lawmen from I don't know poverty I think
it's like corruption if you're a retired
cop and then it's like the cartel goes
soil you need money while you're working
at Wendy's
you know like Oh didn't you arrest me
huh okay why don't you come work for us
give us all the details about the cop
world I'll give you $100,000 mmm that's
why Mexican cops are corrupt they don't
get paid enough Mexican awesome Mexico
the cartel
it sounded like Marc Espinoza instead of
Manuel Espinoza when do I ever
understand yo what the [ __ ] is happening
to me [ __ ] I need a spot but in America
there's not that much corruption because
they pay the 80 character key that makes
sense so you there uncorruptible but the
Los Zetas who used to work for the
government said hey why don't we just
take over the cartel biz and they killed
they were supposed to be like the the
the Navy SEALs of Mexico and they said
you know what they're making more money
doing this illegal [ __ ] why don't we do
this [ __ ] honor homie it's more
honorable to get paid or Lyday and then
they [ __ ] went and did
but how about its horchata when it's or
chata
yeah you showed her Joe you move the are
here in the wrong place I'm sure we're
trying to maybe just say faster Ola
no no Harley you said you wanted to be a
cop right yeah thank good I wanted to
for money I didn't want to do it though
yeah I was I mean I was just looking for
another job that I could do three days
12 hours and then we could do we could
be Uncle Sam uncle Chen the next four
days and then go back to hide a youtuber
by night we're also looking at being a
nurse then too
we looked at that but then I want to
carry a gun too and I thought being part
of swallowed them pretty cool and then
be Uncle Sam later never grow up kids I
thought I'd be pretty cool I still have
cop dreams like SWAT team [ __ ]
you have cop friends no do you live very
sad
no it's [ __ ] sad they're not they're
not cool cops they're not they're not
cool right tickets and they catch bad
guys
I want speed ball helicopter repelling
type of cops you not me I want to be a
card exist in real life yes yeah but you
gotta do what our friends do and then
get selected yeah I just want to give
out tickets and that's it you look like
that guy you want to he's gonna be a
tournament you mean yep at least I'm
gonna live [ __ ] no you're probably
gonna get a harassing a mother to rescue
all you want I'm just gonna do [ __ ]
there's a officer that guy stealing that
[ __ ] that's cool you're the kind of cop
that goes to San Marino or Arcadia or
whatever it looks for a little
walkie-talkie hey shits going down
somebody else do somebody no i'll give
this guy a ticket right now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]